une production du studio sf mais elle
nous sans filtre le podcast on parle de
ce qu'on veut que nos invités dati site
super h 30 ans avec moins d'hommes
plantes
vous nous voyez on établit en hiver
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui le podcast
est présenté par et higuain
ce que savait que dans un manteau
d'hiver en moyenne 12 ou oies et un
coyote
ça fait treize animaux en moyenne dans
un manteau d'hiver puis les alternatives
et gagnent souvent sont pas bonnes pour
l'environnement c'est du plastique mais
éthique les warm ça répond à toutes ces
questions là parce qu'on n'a pas besoin
de faire le choix entre les animaux ou
l'environnement
on peut respecter tout ça en même temps
une entreprise de montréal qui produit
des manteaux vegan écologiques
biodégradables à 80 % biodégradable tous
les produits sont faits par une
coopérative de couturière donc dans le
respect des employés évidemment en ce
moment sont dans une campagne de sociaux
financement qui termine le 30 octobre
fait que vous avez encore le temps
d'aller participer à leur campagne de
sociaux financement de commander un
manteau ou de le recevoir avant noël
avant le temps des fêtes
quand ça commence à être réellement
froid et vous pouvez aussi offrir ses
manteaux en cadeau donc c'est une
compagnie support et eakin compagnie est
vraiment proche de six travailleurs puis
on est ultra fièrement fait de
s'associer avec eux parce que ça
respecte définitivement notre éthique à
nou puis nos valeurs à nous donc merci
beaucoup
puis allez voir si on va mettre le lien
vers leur campagne de soutien au
financement dans la description de la
vidéo en plus de stocker vous pourrez il
faut alors je pense que je vais demander
si je peux lui acheter parce que je
trouve vraiment sur moi et me tuerait
l'acheter sur leurs campagnes sociaux
financement lien mais non mais moi aussi
je ferais confortable pauvres et non
deux comme commanditaire aujourd'hui les
terriens terriens les comptables que
vous connaissez qui sont souvent le on
les adore on fait affaire avec un autre
des jeux ils sont super gentils en gros
ses 25 ans d'expérience dans le domaine
pour des petites et moyennes entreprises
de 1 à 100 employés la vente affaire a
vécu c'est que vous avez pas besoin de
leur expliquer votre modèle d'affaires
sont déjà habitués ils travaillent avec
des créateurs web des journaux format
tic
biotechnologies jeu vidéo toutes les
industries innovantes
ils pourront vous aider à maximiser vos
retours des crédits d'impôt r&d cdae et
multimédia ou d'aucune disent que s'ils
cherchent mais je ne recherche pas la
dernière c'est r&d évidemment le les
entrepreneurs qui nous écoutent qu'ils
savent vous allez me trouver cave mais
pour tout le monde qui savaient pas
comme nous recherche et développement
r&d et recherche doit céder à ces
développements jeu-là derniers sont au
courant dans tous les cas pis il vous
offre un système d'impartition comptable
ça veut dire qu'ils deviennent carrément
votre département de comptabilité à un
prix raisonnable pour une pme alors est
plaqué d'un italien puisse non l'oci en
fait tinter rien juste pour finir 50%
sur votre première année financière si
vous mentionnez que vous avez entendu
parler d'eux parle sans filtre fixé de
l'argent que vous allez pouvoir investir
vous de votre côté et en fait
spécialement aujourd'hui on a un
troisième annonceur parce qu'ils étaient
que les one man x une campagne de ce
financement qui termine le 30
on voulait le mettre rapidement dans les
podcasts mais on remercie également
planethoster de nous faire encore
confiance pleine brousse 200 sociétés
d'hébergement web os tant pour les
particuliers que pour les grosses
entreprises qui ont besoin d'un site web
complexes que pour par exemple nous
studio sfr ne fait affaire avec eux ils
nous ont pris par la main pour faire
notre changement de serveur c'était
vraiment super simple on avait un back
and forth pratiquement constant avec les
gens de planethoster ils font ils
offrent 1 25% pour les organismes à but
non lucratif
il peut également la balance de vos mots
restant avec un autre société
d'hébergement fait que si vous changez
vers planethoster par exemple vous ré
suis moi votre contrôle un taux sur vous
a fui mois gratuits service à la
clientèle exceptionnel comme je disais
et si vous utilisez le code ph a
majuscule trade union centre et nyon
filtre vous avez 25 % sur tout ce que
vous achetez chez planethoster donc
merci à tous nos commanditaires de faire
confiance au sens fait le podcast sans
que monster et pas de podcasts sympa de
caste il n'y a pas de podcasts fait
qu'on veut des podcasts des brodequins
sinon par l'unfp
parlant de podcasts on est ici pour un
podcast fait que cette semaine vraiment
content de rencontrer kim gingras une
danseuse professionnelle à la carrière
exceptionnelle qui est parti du québec
faire carrière à los angeles à la dansé
avec toutes les plus grandes stars du
monde de la musique et justin timberlake
beyonce christina aguilera jennifer
lopez rien à grande et j'en oublie plomb
une école des pussycat dolls parce que
j'ai pas capable d'être son ami
et vraiment c'est si vraiment l'exemple
de la personne qui suit ses rêves que
jamais leur chekireb abandonné malgré
les refus malgré les obstacles qu'il
continu ait vraiment un exemple de
persévérance de travail de rigueur de
passion vraiment belle rencontre
quelqu'un qui ça fait longtemps que je
connaissais en fait mon ex des communes
10,6 idoles que j'ai quand même appris
c'était qui puis après ça cet été j'en
parle pas foule dans podcast métier j'ai
fait une comédie musicale une joue pas
souvent je rencontrais pleine danse arts
plastiques au maintien d'une va
tellement passionnant des belles choses
à connaître à comprendre puis kim c'est
comme la leur la personne rêvée pour qui
parler de ce merveilleux domaine ouais
vraiment people
vraiment c'est énorme et je pense que
c'est un domaine que j'ignorais
complètement puis la conversation et ses
portes et d'elle-même c'était super les
fans de sport vous allez l'aimer aussi
puis l'introduction est déjà assez
longue comme ça comme ça fait qu'on
voulait juste en fait profiter du
podcast puis écran se faire chaud dans
le studio
habillés pour l'hiver le fait tic est
bon parce qu'à ce rythme on écoute
[Musique]
est-ce donc alors se permettre d'être
une personne nationale les deux
[Rires]
commerces et à fort j'avais un show à
québec
le belge était tranquille village et
fallait chausser les gemmes en même
temps c'est comme on vit au maximum
ouais ouais on avait pas de cas cet
après-midi et 1 de li fait le jeu pour
aller sur 7 mais cette fois le campus
attrapé par l'acte et à québec parce
qu'ils étaient vraiment plus souvent un
nouveau cap koné puis dans le fond le 38
ans et habite chez lui ouais je suis
très proche de ma famille donc très bon
4 5 fois par année chez direct et puis
je reçois chez ma mère de me charger 300
donc comme une grosse famille mais là
c'est sûr que ça fait plus de sens si
fred way qui s'est commencé de l'espèce
de bach est forte comme ceux avec avec 2
2 places dans ta vie dans ton coeur dont
le t2 deux endroits qui sont importants
peut-être pas parts égales je ne sais
pas mais mais comme en cdd comme étant
deux en deux lieux
mais où est ce que moi ce que je suis en
ce moment je suis vraiment bien si je
trouve que j'ai la chance de pouvoir
justement tu m'as produit d'abord puis
de l'autre c'est sûr que quand je suis
déménagé à los angeles
j'ai vraiment tout mis de côté par
rapport à que c'est à montréal
je me suis dit il faut vraiment je tente
ma chance je veux pas je lui tenais à me
démanger avant j'avais 10 ans pax comme
plus vieille
- pour en pagne danseuses ne pas être là
bas il recommencer à zéro
mais j'ai vraiment mis toute mon énergie
à los angeles
je voulais pas prendre de vacances je
les patrons promener ont vraiment être
là pour rien c'est un peu la peur de
manquer à l'appel
une addition importante mais quand on
aime beaucoup le début commencer ça au
début c'était aussi je retournais c'est
vraiment ya deux jours et je repartais
n'est menacée j'étais je suis vraiment
content d'avoir une belle carrière à
élite s'est pas terminée mais j'ai quand
même peut-être le tour et que je peux me
permettre un peu plus apte à montréal de
dire oui à des jobs ici d'enseignés
beaucoup plus d'accès fon d'avoir la
liberté de choisir une place selon ce
que tu penses que ça prend dans ce genre
de média artistique ou est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui aspirent à
très peu d'emplois
est ce que tu penses que c'est
nécessaire de faire un peu comme quand
on fait de dire pas de plan b
pitié pendant x années ça va être juste
du grind sans arrêt c'est sûr c'est
beaucoup travaillent puis si tu penses
que ça va juste harvey puis ça arrive à
quelques-uns que ça leur tombe d'aimé
nouma noir très très très rare le fait
que c'est sûr que je pense que le monde
c'est si facile de voir le côté luxueux
puis world big l'amt et même si ces
réseaux sociaux c'est la belle vie c'est
facile mais tout le travail qui fait ça
avance at il n'y avait pas de vie en
tant que cadeau là c'était juste la
danse dance dance dance dance
je manquais télé fait d'amis puis les
soupers de famille puis je dansais
quasiment 24 heures sur 24
taxer beaucoup d'entraînement donc
sacrifices même chose des ménages est
allé c'est un job à tout le monde a tout
de la sécurité la danse ont fait que
c'est beaucoup de travail mais je pense
que ça fait une grosse différence que
j'ai pas de plan b at elle déclaré
ça va être difficile des fois je me
remette en question je suis fait un prix
bon chemin
mais jamais je me dis ok je sais pas ce
que c'est la bonne affaire que sean
ouais c'est ça ouais c'est toujours ça
ma plaie je me levais le matin c'est ça
je voulais faire face je dis à mes
étudiants se lève le matin puis tu as
envie de faire seule voix ziti n'importe
qui vont se fermer mais continue à
bûcher et exemple bien aussi jeudi sony
pourrait je pense trois quatre fois puis
dès la première fois j'aurais pu dire ok
non c'est pas pour moi j'en retire
d'abord puis je change de rêve mais je
voyais soit plus comme un peu plus près
d'eux
but à chaque fois que je reviens je
retravaille et sur ce genre bien fait
enfin staff et c'est mal mais on ne
reviendrait à beyoncé mais on préfère un
peu comme on dit quand était ado oui ça
peut faire un peu la rétrospective de
danger peut noter que moi c'est quand
même temps comment ça que nous la
moyenne mais c'est sûr que tu jamais
beaucoup déjà la danse et fashion show à
l'école d'affaires de même township
je faisais ça mais financièrement ma
famille avait pas l'argent pour
maintenant des cours de danse jusqu'à
temps que justement c'est quelque chose
qui est dispendieux comme si tu es le
genre de sport ça dépend si tu fais
beaucoup de compétitions la cie les
enregistrements pour les conflits tout
seul j'en ai pas fait tant que ça mais
c'est au début on n'avait pas vraiment
les moyens
enfin que j'ai commencé à 15 ans de
l'école pour moi c'est quand même très
important j'étais à l'université en
physiothérapie
si je travaillais fort qui ont été
avertis de montréal que moi j'ai pas
fini à moitié chemin le mon bac c'est là
que j'ai fait à quai j'aime vraiment la
danse jeux d'entraînements quitte les
auditions qui se passe en journée le
faut je fasse un choix d'accessoires
pour moi quand j'étais ado c'est là que
j'ai réalisé que c'était possible de
faire ça comme carrière ou du buste est
plus facile folle jeunesse
mais après ça j'ai commencé à rencontrer
des canadiens et des canadiennes que eux
en fait justement le mouv a élé qui ont
dansé pour des grands dans la grande
histoire justement une en particulier
qu'elle est connue est habilement
couvert il est si jolie dolly c'est
super beau son parcours puis tellement
de belles personnes qui justement j'ai
commencé à prendre des cours d'elle si
elle qui me montre un petit peu le
chemin de ses coiffures improbables
remise au travail si et quand même des
choses va falloir tout accumulé d'aussi
que ça commence à flasher pour moi comme
acquis c'est ce que je préfère c'est ça
me tente beaucoup
donc c'est ça que je pense j'avais 21 à
peu près quand j'ai décidé de quitter
l'université
je me suis lancé à 100% ici à montréal
j'ai une très belle carrière j'ai
beaucoup travaillé que geneviève dorion
coupal qui s'occupait plein de projets
de télé de prod et toupie mais là ça me
chicotait encore le niveau longtemps
deux voies avec la dette un concert que
j'ai fait une coupe de voyage à aller ça
va donner beaucoup de goût mais pour
être honnête j'avais que ce même acheté
une maison ici je tends coupe dans ce
temps là avec un meilleur ami maintenant
vincent loisir très grand danseur à lui
dans sa note en ce moment puis aussi
québécois mon soutien on a fait le tour
ça va bien on a une belle vie ici on
travaille beaucoup et on s'achète une
maison s'installe le gie par la coupe de
personnes ne tienne comme le mentor qui
m'ont dit mais là kim s'est même temps
près de 5 en avant par un achat mais ça
c'est le genre de ce genre de moments
dans une vie où est ce que tu dis ok
deux chaises
j'apprends toujours faire ce choix leurs
pigeons et espère y ait pas cet avis
mais tout ça c'est qu'on nous oblige à
suivre mon cas de faire quelque chose
qui met à que j'aime mais ça a été
complètement différent c'est ça que je
me sens comme remise à replanter un puce
s est déjà dans la tête qu'ils n'ont
elles essaient vraiment où est ce qu'on
veut aller
après tout c'est comme bien des filets
sweeting camden saison 1 canada moi j'ai
fait deux saisons 2 c'est sûr ça donne
une belle carte forme prononce appliqué
pour nos visas de travail par les
connexions à los angeles aux etats-unis
en 2011 on ait déménagé est assez morale
mais j'en viens à caen pour moi de
commencer parce que tim est en outre la
fed qui ont fait du sport mme et ont
commencé un sport la natation à 15 ans
et comme il est impensable quelques
quelques exemples ça arrive jamais
meetic 3d commence il faut que tu
apprennes tous les sites légaux
différents styles qui développe aussi la
musculature hôpital est toutes les
souplesses pour faire ce point c'est sûr
qu'acheter limité je t'aime à côté
souple et flexible
des jeeps a commencé emballé quand
j'étais jeune dans à côté de moi c'est
plus et danses urbaines 17 août que
c'était plus commercial commercial
souvent la vidéo clip
la pression je prenais des cours de de
house de looking de huaqing
effectivement tout rester dans l'urbain
de la pression j'ai découvert pour ses
talons hauts c'est côté féminin que je
t'ai j'étais vraiment bien là dedans
mais si j'y comprends un peu passé à
côté de toutes qu'est ce que t'es ballet
était vraiment la formation classique
louey c'est ce que j'aurais aimé sauter
mais mon corps était comme c'est
possible que j'aurais plus poussées ça
mais mon coeur est et dans tout ce que
ces termes un commercial mais c'est
s'agit potiche mais je me serais pas là
ouais c'est au début était capable ou
non tout ce que la boj avait fait tous
les matches mais c'est quelque chose que
c'est ça j'en parle beaucoup et aux
élèves surtout quand je reviens ici au
québec pouvoir donner des nouvelles
générations de danseurs tout ce que vaut
mettre les battons nehru en passant que
je peux pas me rendre à tel quel point
ça c'est parce que j'y manque une
certaine techniquement c'est possible
c'est foutu thème en tant que personnes
avec des qualités et des défauts puisque
tu as apporté témoin j'ai misé au québec
j'ai pas ça mais je touche plus performé
je travaille vraiment fort j'ai donc tué
jaurès belle énergie dans l'équipe s'est
fait que en tout quelque chose à
apporter à offrir mais c'est ce qui
t'inspire ajustement de de savoir dit de
voir quelqu'un un exemple de quelqu'un
qui atteint son rêve mais qui qu'il a
peut-être découvert à 56 2 en mai
mettant les bouchées doubles bien en
voulant que ça finit par fonctionner
absolument
c'est sûr que ma famille et avoir qu'une
famille comme ça qui me supporte sa 100%
picot tu veux arrêter les colloques et
n'y avait pas de médecin faire quoi puis
comme un transfert d'argent qui s'est tu
veux faire s'évader age de glace été
volée puis atr ma mère a vraiment cru en
moi puis était derrière moi peu importe
ce qui se passe et puis je l'appelais à
chaque jour quand je t'aime je déménage
et là vous donner tout l'épisode des
possibles qui s'était vraiment derrière
moi ma famille aussi mais sam on parle
tout le monde
c'est fou est ce que justement tu disais
que je vais mettre les bouchées doubles
et avons une bougie
avec ce cd cd sans dire prérequis est ce
que c'est vraiment important dans pomme
pour l'ascension dans ce télé spes de
l'espèce de réputation que tu te fais
que tu que tu forgé autour de toi que
les gens aiment travailler avec toi qui
ont envie de retravailler est-ce que ce
ça compte pour plus que le talent
n'étant lui dans ce sens et quand
longévité c'est sûr que si tu parles
d'une audition il faut donc quelque
chose à offrir
même si l'énergie ouais on s'en fout
ouais c'est ça qui au début c'est celle
de bois par un dans le temps si tu
décides pitt engage une antique mais la
presse est ce que tu veux te faire
rappeler par cette équipe le savez tout
le côté énergie du travail qui porte et
armateurs est ce que tu charles que tu
aimes pas tomber coop et écouter j'en ai
vu des choses je te laisse à côté d'une
fille qui ont incité des chaises de
maquillage comme un outil mais tout est
enregistré et des yeux partout faire
attention
est ce que t on en parlait autrefois
pour les gays en musique où est ce que
tu peux pas beaucoup de prise avant un
retrait c'est de fermer ton d'arrivée
soit d'arriver en retard sur guy gouttes
et c'est tellement un milieu qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui aspirent comme
interchangeables si on veut ta
réputation c'est ce que toutes plus
précise justement de tuchan petit dessus
alors c'est un autre mais je parlais
qu'il faut que tu dises acquis et pas de
plan b fait qu'on y va tuer en ligne
avec ce plan leurs pions on prend pas de
vacances parce qu'on veut pas manquer un
appel on veut tout le temps disponible
on va être ponctionne va être alors
j'imagine que la tolérance pour ces
affaires lui doit être vraiment pas du
tout cas tu arrives sur des preuves le
mondial l'international
ouais des deux côtés de rester
professionnel
ouais c'est sûr c'est super important
parce qu'en même temps tu cherches
d'aider des relations avec des
chorégraphes toute simple le définit
comme au début je faisais beaucoup
d'additions mais maintenant je me fais
appeler directement dispo pour ça pour
ça parce que ça que je vais être capable
d'accomplir ce qu'ils ont besoin que
j'accomplis surtout des fois ce qu'on
appelle le turnaround cycle entre
l'audition quand on est engagé
l'inspecteur quelqu'un peut-être juste
une demi-journée de répète dès après son
mandat simple c'est cholet gros galette
et du moment où ce qui n'engage moins
jusqu'à ce que le chocolat à quelqu'un
qu'il va falloir tu répètes cinq fois la
même correction thé vous que soit vite
pour ce soir à pied de soi que ce que
j'appelle un danseur intelligent dans ce
sens que s que je capable de deux par
moi même ça qu'on me dise réalisé que
acquis telle affaire de feu ici
oui j s kids en chemin je vais faire
attention où je réalise faut que je
monte par ce côté là parce que c'est
bloqué à cause des bouteilles des yeux
tout le tour des sages prennent des
initiatives qui fit avec avec le
l'accueil graphismes assez satisfait moi
qui en charge de venir porter le micro à
l'artiste diane bisson mentaux mais
c'est moi c'est à moi d'aller laisser
avancer le chorégraphe optait pas penser
à ce qu'on me porte 5,6 et chapeau
différent s'occupe de tout l'ensemble
moi j'allais voir la costumière ce que
je prévois le manteau il est haché sa
tâche comme un ok parfait si c'est tout
ce côté là de prendre ça les initiatives
des professeurs mais tantôt avant qu'on
se mette à tourner tudyk des fois pour
des shows c'est mettons des gros shows
comme le sprint pour les grammys ça peut
être quatre cinq semaines de répit mais
des fois c'est aussi vraiment aussi
rappelé que c'est très rapide des
émissions je me taperais ces questions
là on y reviendra peut-être tantôt de
mai comme quand le quand tu vois
maintenant il ya un gars le à chaque
semaine 1 arrive à chaque semaine pour
la voie puis le il ya trois artistes qui
ont 3 4 ans et scelle après l'arrivée à
los angeles j'ai bouquet extra cus la
première saison qui se passait là bas
puis on était ce qu'on appelle les
alouettes et à monsieur pascal et
danseurs qui sont là pour tout les
artistes classe même si je pense qu'on
apprenait une douzaine de corps et par
semaine parce que les artistes dans ce
cas seulement pour tout les artistes à
moins qu'ils fassent une balade tu fais
quelque chose dans numéro mais là c'est
l'artiste s'est préparé une chanson plus
de jours de taris l'oeuf puis dire non
je vais pas chanter sa nouvelle offre
mais là tout l'accord ebeam héros aux
poubelles
comme harnes et on en apprenait des
numéros mais c'est la meilleure école la
formation continue sa peau de la
choréale existe parce que c'est très
grave café puis vous là où la montée
ensemble comment ça fonctionne ça dépend
des chorégraphes donc six mois sont
quand même il arrive assez préparés ont
souvent des assistants qui les ont aidés
qui on peut parler sud avant c'était si
jamais c'était pas beaucoup de temps
plein qui doit être prête juste une
journée timides arrivent avec l'accord
et de fêtes puis sinon exemple si on
prend bien de ces qui elle va prendre
des semaines des fois se préparer si
c'est plus qu'on appelle du workshop et
à qui on essaie sont nécessaires non
plan b qui ont à ses débuts l'homme et
avec la fin de l'onu mais roque ont
essayé de tuer fait qu'on joue puis
aussi dépendant des danseurs c'est ce
qu'on peut faire si elle allait à
l'essai split acquis mais je t'aime en
avant février
mais tu pourrais pas demander ça à moi
c'est comme ça dépend avec qui travaille
aussi fait tu peux jouer perd 6 à faire
est-ce que ce qui est des fois mettons
dans une preuve comme ex facteur humain
la contrainte de temps de temps
restreint fait que des fois tu arrives
avec une grotte comme ok oil si c'était
juste y le tessin s'y attende trop
versus une corée qui est vraiment
travailler puisque l'eau tu sais que tu
vas arriver à un produit fini qui est
que tu aimes que tout le monde aime mais
est-ce que des fois comme j'imagine que
s'il ya des réformistes dans une prod
comme seul quand même avec des
professionnels qui prennent pas le butin
ouais c'est ça fait des bonnes des bons
résultats mais c'est toujours
impressionnant parce que justement quand
c'est rapide un manque de pot le temps
de sortir de tout ce qui se passe que de
regarder
justement le résultat tandis que pour
quelque chose de quatre cinq semaines
ont des vidéos ça de l'art de quoi est
ce que tu as soit je regarde toujours le
fun pour qu'est ce qui est plus rapide
d'après ce que j'avais aucune dispense
et de là il y avait de la pire ou en
arrière comme vidéo accès qu'aux prix
ouais c'est c'est fou c'est chou bêtises
moi mon ex est en fait la voiture puis
j'avais été sur place puis à quel point
justement sur ces chaudes les décisions
se prennent rapidement comme tu disais
ça peut changer tout naveil ça peut
faire vite et moi j'étais tout le temps
vraiment impressionné des musiciens à
quel point il se revirer de bord et non
jamais réalisé que les danseurs c'est là
aussi trop souvent cela peut-être rien
mais même si surprenant ça c'était du
côté jardin de la scène tout le monde
est ok mais on va tendre côté tac
traverse faut qu'ils changent tout
l'accueil la fille qui fait miroir
vraiment simple accueil écoute changé
par huawei a ajouté l'athlète arriva est
liée en 2011
ouais pis le petit a pas de comptes
repris boukil non c'est ça tel le petit
gars tiga tchad du visa de travail que
tu dois montrer qu'un calendrier de
trois ans de plus qui plein de ce qu'on
appelle un deal memo qui a plein de
travail qui t'attend ça ne va s'engager
à ce propos sur la tête approchent
certains chorégraphes avec qui tu es tu
as des connexions pièces que je peux tu
as hâte assisté sur telle ou telle
affaire qui parfait avec l'as tu remplis
mais ils savent qu'ils ont besoin ce qui
les expose ans pour tout le temps mais
moi j'étais française quand même le
monde avec qui je travaillais déjà ou
que j'avais que j'ai une connexion et on
finit par tout de m'engager après tignes
qui met ses pas et rien n'assure et
arrive la botte des ménages peloter moi
j'avais cinq mille ans mon compte de
sauver les sabots vulcan moins cinq mois
ça absolument site el manchar le coup de
tabac pilates et espère que ça m'a pris
quelques mois j'ai fait qu'est ce qu'ils
font c'est que les québécois puits
canadien devant une belle réputation
parce que on y répond par pas le temps
des pantins de se tourner les pouces
heures à la maison l'attitude n'envoie -
les éditions même si c'est quelque chose
de nouveau je me déguise en banane je
vois le fragile
le discours j'ai besoin job parce que si
je veux que rien vraiment 3a s'écroule
mais là je vois pourrait l'oublier
grâce à l'accès se fait que je me suis
vraiment et je me suis lancé dans toutes
les éditions possible peu après quelques
mois
côté des auditions que tu aimerais mieux
oublier ses examens c'est ça rien de
trop 3 une méthode en as tu fait de ton
métier dans quel ordre en attendant
première année matin sur des dizaines
des centaines d'haïtiens j'agirai
peut-être pas jusqu'à ça mais c'est 40
50 60
au début cette erreur je me rappelle une
phrase audition j'ai fait c'était pour
good things dans un club donc du coup
dancing pour ceux qui écoutent qui
s'appelait pas c'est quoi c'est quand tu
vois les les faits ou légaux qui dans
surplus sur une boîte et de ville sur un
petit podium qui utilisent l'ambiance
d'un club 1 kg ma fureur way back furent
pour ceux qui côtoient face à face à
saint gaudens
je me situe à qui j'en ai fait des
années que ça va bien aller
en plus c'était dans ma zone de confort
plus sexy talons hauts à tichy bien là
d'un problème je m'en bats l'addition
n'est plus un plein dans serge coupé dès
le 1er parenté j'aime tout chez moi puis
comme acquis ouah je me suis même pas
rendu co2 et des maisons c'est assez
facile tant à dire pourquoi foule
l'entraînement pour tellement fait
désordre de toi que je très bien
là-dedans d'improvisation tout seul puis
metz et je rappelle maman encore michael
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait le jeu des
ménagères et faugères cofondé 0 comment
je vais vous quelque chose de plus gros
des accès si tu te remets en question
rapidement mais c'est là que j'ai
réalisé qu'il fallait que je change ma
façon de penser de pas me descendre et
s'efface iran nous on a toutes nos
petites boîtes à l'intérieur tish je
peux bouge pas bien je passe ici je
passais sur teamspeak rapidement fallait
que j'ignore ce que je change de
transformer quelque chose de positif
kim qui mérite d'être ici de travailler
fort justement parce qu'il ya un
meilleur oui qui s'en vient s'il fallait
vraiment que je change ma façon de
penser qui restait positive non ça tu
avales tout rond le los angeles le sait
toutes les mères des meilleurs qu'ils
disent
le monde en toile ça prenne confiance
béton ah ouais c 'est pas trop douter
ton nom c'est dans sa ville
sa vie est avalée tour en temps on était
si je compare à montréal
1 éditions et si c'était ton une
trentaine de personnes puis je connais
pas mal tout le monde s'est pendu des
amis constitue une chance puis j'espère
que j'adore sajjad et déménagea à lyon
les gens à 800 filles car j'aurais
peut-être dû hisser dessus
ci-dessus comme l'espèce de l'image
qu'on se fait que tu arrives là c'est
tout le monde qui ont donc à sting paie
moi en tant qu route y en a moins mais
c'est sûr qu'on a été beaucoup plus que
si la ici je prépare sa tête du ou trois
danseuses que quand je fus groupe s'est
tous pointé le monde connaît mais à elle
et c'est sûr que beaucoup de monde qui
t'ont casting ouais c'est fou c'est que
c'est commun c'est que c'est là la lande
way voie lactée kat von d a fait un
autre sillon pis c'est juste des filles
qui ont le même piège ouais ouais super
cadeaux
c'est surtout vrai ça doit se
prostituent dit les saisies ne doit pas
bâtir là très tôt mais c'est tellement
facile surtout d'avoir un groupe aussi
petit écart à facile de commencer à se
dire qu'est ce que je fais ici sur ben
meilleur jeu peut être choisie thème
encore faute européenne a pris
rapidement 10 90 j'ai ma place pour peau
de ce gène et outils font ce qu'ils
étaient il ya quand même faux du golfe
c'est vraiment pas tout le monde obscur
qui fait pour ce nom
si j'ai parlé je te manges menteurs
quand même plusieurs danseurs l'as bopp
ici aussi bien en une en particulier tic
est là se connaît très bien ces tests
etc tout d'abord parce que tout jeune
fille était comme kim je pensais pas
pour moi je penche vers des ménages et
la maison avoir à me battre pour être en
avant comme woippy que c'est pas moi ça
me tente pas obligé discret c'est pas
pour tout le monde mais la moitié
s'étaient rendus ce qui s'y passait une
audition plateaux-repas de world food et
et ça veut dire que tu sais c'est que
c'est pour toi c'est comme je te dise
elle s'était jetée sur mamma mia theman6
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer plein
danseurs danseuses sa mère incroyable
qui plusieurs sont en ces questions a
commenté son début mi vingtaine
je fais ce que je veux les grosses
questions ne s'est pas hissé faut se
connaître en maudit savoir
je suis vraiment envie de ce mois août
et où je veux continuer d'aller à
l'université à temps partiel en même
temps dans ces pays c'est justement il y
en a une quarantaine en ce moment je te
manquer qui participe à mon un mois et
demi je pense qu'ils avaient retourné
factice et cbc s'est jeté dans le vide
en mode il s'est tu pendant coupe de
motifs de votre compte en banque de sang
de l'acquisition et qui rentrent
pillowman tête touche le fond ouais
absolument que moi je me suis dit c'est
justement j'en faisais c'était ma
carrière ici poussée c'est juste que je
faisais je vivais de la danse
je me suis acquitté pour porter atteinte
aux droits sont peut-être par la moitié
en se croisant les doigts tu es quand ce
bar refaeli pour la première année mais
j'ai fini par faire le double parce que
la première année un type à scruter jeu
contente j'ai travaillé tout cela mais
aussi c'est beaucoup mieux pays voit ses
sols et les budgets doivent jouer le
double bien vivre c'est quoi le premier
guigou est ce que tout est ce que tu as
eu un genre de feeling de ouf j'ai fait
le sale petit marseille maintenant pas
ça paye monétaire mam est invaincu
servier j'avais beaucoup d'affaires déjà
mais c'est comme si c'était une pub ici
là mais il y avait une édition qui se
passait pour le psychiatre danse et ça
c'est la principale puis j'aimais
beaucoup ce couple a quand même face à
des marchés avec le côté un peu plus
féminin de ça puis a fait une audition
pour un vidéoclip pour une de ses
nouvelles chansons mais j'ai pas eu le
col fait une enfance qui dit a toujours
un genre de que des détails de qu'est ce
qu'on cherche c'est la grandeur la
densité tout ça puis je n'étais pas là
dedans mais j'ai appris mon agent qui
arrêtent qu'on peut pas rentrer non jeu
désolé je peux pas ça marche pas avec
les critères qui cherchent à qui le [ __ ]
est le chorégraphe qui s'occupaient de
ça parce que j'ai fait un show avec
quelques années
juste pour le fun le japon reste que je
peux venir bien cachés tiendra à leurs
problèmes ok avec le je me rends là ça a
été une audition qui a duré toute la
journée jusqu'à je pense qu'à minuit
nicole est arrivé à terme de faire
danser un par intérim bob je veux
tellement la voir ça va tellement été
plus un journal par épuisant émotivement
aussi comme émotionnellement tout ce que
tu aimais fc drainant au boutte
puis j'ai été choisi avec le système
pour leur ait un vidéoclip de décrocher
ce vieux jeu mais sans savoir que ça
c'est devenu après une performance qu'on
a fait sur ellen degeneres
après ça c'est devenu un autre vidéo qui
est perdant vidéoclip une tournée en
europe il a justement dans deux semaines
je m'en vais en indonésie avec quel
point l'auteur nous donnons un futur et
la job qu'ils arrêtent pas de donner le
sait mais quand j'ai bouquet ce je me
situe à qui le savent à quoi je pense
que ça a commencé à rouler le j'ai fait
le bon choix fait que la première qui te
donner cette chance le studio ouais
d'accord avec elle qu'elle est tellement
c'est ma fin de récolte et puis j'ai
avec elle pendant un gros bout de temps
la pression j'ai fini par bouquet bien
ici et qu'il fallait challenge désolé je
prie plus forte est chaud c'est bien
aussi mais en auxiliaires et puis de
jalousie au québec tous très bons avec
moi je ne suis pas bien c'est fini tu
aimais non pas pantoute à ces seuils
toujours à chaque fois tu étudies
pokemon co habitat qui n'ont fait que le
ghana côté après 7,6 il a eu bien c'est
juste a menti à agen avec mes amis
danseurs je vais souvent plus gai c'est
parce que parce que le type c'est la
première fois que comme j'ai une
incursion dans ce monde là que je
connaissais pas du tout et puis je veux
porter jean tong ont fini par porter
dans les discussions éventuellement d'y
jeter les caisses qui fait que kim
[Musique]
j'aurai quelque pourquoi elsa dans
marché autant dire la réponse souvent
qui donnait ce cas elle voulu baisser le
talent et le cca le voulu plus que
n'importe qui
il ya le fait les auditions une fois
deux fois trois fois que je sais pas
combien de fois de la tête mais c'était
toujours retourner c'est peut-être ça
c'est mon rêve piges je veux pas lâcher
avant que ça se passe
en plus avec avec le premier gain que tu
peux les tournées que s'en viennent
certains pourraient dire on fait juste
et sur mon rêve c'est finalement pas mal
reçue le 10 juin j'avais en tête beyoncé
mais comme là c'est ridicule c'est good
enough
c'est quand même non c'est très possible
ce n'est pas ça qu'il y avait aussi un
côté un peu magique du fait qu'on était
les premiers québécois se rendent à et
les adrets que j'ai peur parce que je
pense que les autres qui veulent se
rendre n'y voient que c'est possible
la preuve le site de paris de voir loin
je le mets en même temps justement
l'inconnu sida comme acquis mais je vois
pas revenir je paie trop confortable
faire dévier montréal estime qu y est
pas et pour une mauvaise réponse mauvais
chemin et et mais je pense qu'on s'est
vraiment lancée sans vraiment même y
penser que c'était possible de faire les
deux premiers ont dit non le bookeen
josé aurait tout est capable de le faire
seul ouais moi s'arrêter je pense
emotionnellement petit peu plus
difficile sûrement plus d'aperam a
longtemps quand même quand c'est avoir
la tv web tellement loin comme ce jeune
autiste je veux pas beau ce titre mais
le ps d'initiales c'est un appartement
jade est un peu dans un jeu trop ça
commence mais déjà c'est ce que je
suggère aux danseurs qui veulent
peut-être parce c'est allé faire une
coupe de voyager j'avais quand même été
plusieurs fois j'ai fait j'ai suivi une
convention qui s'appelle monde sur le
papillon toujours un genre de gros
showcase à la fin de l'année où est-ce
qu'ils choisissent quatorze danseurs
total de toutes les villes qu'on fait si
je demande ce jour là que j'ai fait tout
ce que j'ai rencontré le regard de nico
qui aussi le chorégraphe de beyoncé qui
le que regarder de près le monde qui
étaient avec nous en tant que danseur on
a fait le lien puis après s'il ya fini
par me till m'engager sur plein de
choses
actis arrête de voir des terrains peu
thème de lycées tous pour toi fais des
connexions avec même si c'est pas de
canadiens ou de québécois avec toi tu
étais quand même quelques amis
qui habite le déjanté après le talent le
côté pierre est important aussi c'est
trop là les douanes avoir à courir les
rues même au début je la faisais moi je
te dirais que ça a pris deux trois ans
que je disais qu'ils aient laissé mon
chez moi là ok je la prenne comme un
dieu parce qu'au début j'ai rien sans
karim le monde ces deux facettes c'est
ça dit bonjour bonjour ma précieuse gens
tentent de dire que ça parlait dans mon
dos c'est le monde s'imagine que c'est
plus friendly à montréal on est belle
réputation le monde 2 1 canadiens à
québécois d'alors ouais vraiment on est
gentil revenons justement survient c'est
parce que c'est vraiment intéressant
toi tu as eu un call pour une audition à
kehl ouest fonctionne pas ouais un autre
fonction qu'est ce qui se passe dans
taikang sur tourne encore ouais ben je
me sentais de plus en plus forte à
chaque fois le premier
j'habite encore à montréal j'ai un peu
de vie au travail parce que je faisais
mais j'ai juste vu sur sur les nouvelles
que yann on sait ce qu'on appelle un
open colle pour une édition ça veut dire
que tu pas besoin d'avoir une
représentation mais non c'est ça je te
vas j'embarque dans un boss de montréal
je me range qu'à new york puis à ses
pendants les vacances en janvier ou en
février
ces dix heures et des heures d'attenté
dans le froid lot si ça faisait le tour
du bloc qui le tour du bloc avant de
rentrer deux nations c'était
épouvantable
comment cette erreur est vite arrivée
apparemment de co2 sur l'eau de ce que
de ce qu'on me dit oui c'est que de
voter dans ce même pôle non sûr on
appelle ça un carreau colle quand il ya
tout le monde était un tipi qui font
pincer un tas de casse tout mis en ligne
le thème pas cadencés doit pas parler de
prix ne peut rien fait
le chorégraphe passe plus dans ton
oreille dit jean-louis ste claire et
sous non merci
c'est clair que c'est gras
classe toibin grande mais qui regarde
quoi bomber le regard de tout ton
physique c'est vraiment juste attaché
ton physique ta grandeur tes cheveux tu
es c'est sûr que c'est une blonde visite
bénie et blanc n'avaient pas de blancs
douter et à faire de même ce qui se
passe c'est vraiment pas su que ça crie
parce que des gens qui ont des chèques
qu'ils ont là que tu dis je donne
l'exemple mettons sur mamma mia
c'est ce médium et ont je pense à une
personne en particulier c'était dans son
incroyable vraiment bon danseur pied sur
le sol stage'' magnetix vrai mais tu le
vois tous dit il ya paul physique
habituelle - ouais sauf que ça marche
aux bottines peep ravalement de la
façade en moi je sais pas mais peut être
couplé ouais mais là on avait passé à
côté de quelque chose de absolument non
c'est sûr qu'on a beaucoup de soin puis
justement c'est qu'on est tellement la
demande l'offre est tellement qu'il faut
que je te vois ce que dit que tu hip hop
avec le fait que c'est un choc t6 et
jello légaux y vont de leurs champs
derrière mon année tu sais tu es et tu
discutes pourquoi tu t'en vas auditionné
jacques foutais là cher mais c'est
peut-être que tu travailles tu vu
auditionné pour glee le show glee les
yeux de toutes formes et de toutes
cheick tioté va peut-être une meilleure
chance pour téléphones tout dépendant à
quoi te ressemble mais vous de sacha
plus d'engouement marx il faut pas qu'il
prenne personnel si je mens tu avais pas
lâcher plus grande partie satisfait que
se massifie en tant que pays on va dire
aux 5 8 5/10 puis tu veux danser précis
avec mary qui comme 5 un joli duo qui
ouais c'est ça prend la peau personnel
de la métare gilad est retourné que
christian verron pas ça fait plusieurs
années que trois avec l aps l'enfant un
album la dissidente a comparé les deux
c'est quand tu pars en tournée en
ardoise et puis j'ai reçu un appel de ce
grave quelques semaines avant pic qui me
gentiment expliqué dit ce qui me
contador puis j'ai une part la crise n'a
pas la dernière heure ce qui convainc
engagé le look du visuel de la tournée
puis à la menace avec la seule coque et
jeunes sur le dessus
la scène c'est pour moi la seule blanche
en fait qui vont remplacer pour l'acter
mais c'est correct
moi qui me le disait un autre au match
du pro bowl c'est pour ça mais là je
comprends leur ca fait passer ta games
n'est pas personnel à leur look une
vision pcb collègues savent que ce soit
comme tout mélanger c'est la seule qui
popent blanche était parce qu'il ya plus
de diversité dans les choix justement
des castings qui pourrait avoir avant
parce que mettons mettons que je regarde
les vidéos clips
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya plus de look
ou de de beauté non conventionnelle
absolument c'est super le fun à voir
mais toi aussi je doute quand même un
look non conventionnelles sont veulent
c'est un chevelu qui se tapent dessus de
ça a beaucoup fonctionné pour moi comme
peu savent que je parle pas de mine ont
peut-être mais c'est déjà arrivé
plusieurs fois nantes flash trop où je
t'ai placé juste à côté de l'artiste
ils ont fait un vidéo clip on arrive sur
le plateau de tournage plan le directeur
qui me voient dans camera tvo pour
déchets post j'ai pris 10 tu penses à
prendre une photo qui jettent avec au
monde peut-être un peu plus foncé que
moi le flash flash plus que la première
juste à côté de mon cadet sur le spot et
échangent excuse moi qui aime c'est ça
ton nom qu'ils voyaient peu tu as l'air
narnia qui là que ça se passe des fois
où tu sais qu'ils me tuent petit mettre
une perruque brune tu peux tu t'es je
suis mon trou flash et ça s'est traduit
comme i des perruques qui justement
ouais ouais ça mais je ne sois plus low
profile
nicki bille à ce cas limite mettons ce
qui aujourd'hui pour une blanche blonde
avec un casting conventionnelles sont
des classiques ce que ça peut être plus
si ça dépend de la job je pensais parce
que côté commercial et publicité tout ce
je pense que ça va encore bien jouer ça
va dépendre
on dirait que c'est moins pire dans une
beaucoup d'amis qui sont des acteurs à
aller puis ils disent que cette offre si
je te mettais des tbh l'américaine là
c'est difficile de
trouver des jobs ok fac bf bien sûr mais
c'est ça moi je découvre un demain en ce
moment mais couvrent complètement
quelque chose que j'ignorais que ce
genre d'audition là on dirait que je
sais pas je parlais de comme on attend
tout le monde dans le froid moi entrer
dedans puis avoir une chance de se faire
dire sur une ligne va trancher après
venu jusqu'à jusqu'à new york deux
points pour tous est ce que tu viens à
new york j'ai passé six mois celle de la
pole on dirait s'était dernièrement ici
justice et si c'est rien comparé à seul
mais juste au studio on veut l'engager
qui tient ici puis c'est juste écrire un
email disant quelqu'un est merci
vraiment ton intérêt mais comme on va
notre direction quelqu'un qui a pris du
temps thibault pour nous autres juste
sûr je me sentais que j'avais pas envie
d'envoyer puis le j'imagine parce que
c'était si tu prends cette expérience-là
décuple amener autant pour les danseurs
que pour les gens les chorégraphes les
gens qui prennent des décisions faut que
tu copies sur kung fu que tout il faut
que ça change rien ouais faut que la
personne a soit descendu de l'état jean
haut pour mary sy au cas soit venu
d'australie
si aucune différence et se fout par elle
au début ça fait ça doit détruire des
gens ça doit être complémentaire des
gens absolument
tu vois type c'est si difficile après de
se remonter le moral de tes amis mais tu
peux pas descendre dans la négativité
non plus mais c'est pas tout le monde
qui prend comme la même pas santé en a
que ça passe à autre chose dont j'ai
découpé la pénalité puis en option mais
je me demande pourquoi participants
cependant les prochains deux semaines
puis moi mais c'était ma job j'aurais du
tice
c'est difficile pour vraiment faire une
coupure du vote vers l'audition tu
penses à prochaine petit à petit c'est
une belle surprise si on tape est
perdante at il noté c'est facile à dire
qu'à faire
sûrement dans une échelle plus grande si
c'est un peu nous c'est un peu une façon
avec laquelle on devrait aborder ma
forme
c'est tout en poursuivant les du mode
solution le cédant vidic et comme je ne
me rappelle pas un mais trois airs et
qui ne peut plus chez quelqu'un qui
n'est pas en mode solution battant il ya
un problème car il est quelque chose qui
arrive quelque chose de négatif qui
arrive le tuerie h sur cette affaire
lors d'orages arrêts du jeu parce que
c'est comme ces fêtes étaient allées du
ils servent à rien
c'est à dire oui oui mais mais c'est sûr
mais moi je trouve qu'il s'est assis
avant qu'on va construire à tourner si
je dis que c'est la danse comme une
espèce de d'entre deux le sport est
l'objectif d'être une sainte donné
spectacle mais c'est très physique six
possibles c'est de l'entraînement mais
vous avez cette force le cette
résilience le des athlètes je pense et
de beaucoup plus d'échecs et puis
beaucoup plus de titres temps de
dépasser tu sais toujours pas ton coach
souvent sur ce suspect korek améliore ce
type peut pas le prendre personnel c'est
pire vous êtes toft wales est vraiment
of film où j'ai remarqué c'est justement
encore une fois cet été j'ai remarqué à
quel point dans sa jusqu'à temps que ça
soit pas parfait travail quand ils
travaillent puissent et des longues
journées puissent pas facile puisque on
dire des notes puis c'est des fois dans
le moment c'est pas tout le temps c'est
la renault la poignante actes ou quoi
que ce soit mais c'est comme au quai
puis ils font tpiy puis autre qu une
parenthèse métier mettons versus mettons
des comédiens ou est ce qu est le lard
émotivité pis tout l'arc personnes cc66
la rareté avec des fois une note
ça devient espace personnel où ce parti
touche touché par ce qui s'était
vraiment justement de deux approches du
monde le trio d'enfer ce qui t'amène
paulo et loupe il a quitté puis tandis
qu'une autre comédie c'est quand
nous sommes plus des câbles électriques
en passan il y toucher parce que c'est
là les postes aspect l'offre physique
c'est vraiment plus la subjectivité dans
ta tente en tente à sensibilité le train
mais dans la danse il y associe ça va
plus vite c'est ça c est ce que tu leur
tombre est en bonne place non au québec
je change de place et va quand même
quand il fait une addition plus tête de
la guiguette embarque tout commence les
répétitions tout comme exemple quand
j'ai bouquet la tournée de bien c'est ma
part ma famille proche proche ne l'est
pas non si je les pose aperçus parce que
sa structure bâche spotify serait bon
qu'un ouais c'est arrivé juste avant
pour bien deux c'est ce que s'est passé
mois dans le fond qu'en fait on m'a
appelé j'ai fait le support de
maîtresses avec elle on est juste le
plus gros dégâts on était trente cinq
filles sur ce show là
puis on entendu comme la rumeur qui
était en train de secrètement pu
auditionner cherché à voir parmi les 35
filles qui apprendrait sur sa tournée
qui était pas non mais appliquent avec
douche vous savez rien vraiment d'
avance le nom ton meilleur en répétition
du travail si parfois je mettais des
fossiles arranger chaque matin qu'ils
foutent c'est vraiment plus c'est cool
parce que ça a donné que j'étais une des
filles tester aussi les cheveux qui
voulait peut-être s'est attaché à notre
portée il m'avait pris un petit peu
comme modèle boli pour essayer je peux
pas passer inaperçu en soie mâle la
regarde à travers moi les quelques
semaines ce sens parce se sont écroulés
puis je me suis dit tiens je me suis
démarqué ç'a bien été entendu j'avais
tellement 7-6 6-2 c'est sûr que le super
bowl des méga voir boucler cette phase
avec elle mais moi mon rêve de plus
jeune c'était une tournée monde
avec beyoncé j'aimerais tellement ça
tellement cela les deux semaines après
le super bowl s'écroule puis on savait
qu'à commence et on avait entendu dire
que qui s'intéressent à new york les
répète ça commence et elle s'amuse
ivanco peu importe les deux semaines 6
crew j'entends des amis qui sont bookés
que reçu le courriel finissent tensions
entre le moyen âge à la révolution le
meeddat on s'était secrètement pendant
qu aurait manqué du caire que d'autres
auditions
puis l'agent souvent sous les 35 fille
de 35 ans apprenait combien et on a fini
par être cette eau des buts après ça ne
faut qu'ils voient c'est une bonne gang
de huawei
puis jeudi ou vendredi juste avant ce
samedi qu'elle ait commencé ce jeudi
puis je finis je pense avec une
prochaine fois tu es encore une fois la
jetée rendu à être restée positive s'est
pas non plus et finissez par mois encore
une fois je suis moins ce serait la
prochaine
hadji parce que c'est ça que je veux tu
es là que je reste quand même poussé
puisque règlement sera pour une
prochaine fois je raccroche avec les
bleus poule où je reçois un courriel
dans mon agent kim et on change certains
noms sur la liste bien ici à la vue la
liste pas le changer certaines personnes
pilotée à la mi-temps non festival
histoire tournée mondiale ouais tout une
heure et demi avant sa l'hérault
incroyable ça veut dire qu'à c'est
vraiment toutes vos noms mais vous êtes
qui le sait pour voir les noms fois
sinon celle là que j'aime et polo au pis
ça veut dire que c'est sûr vous connais
les grands comme cela je te dirais la
cipa master elle aussi avant la tournée
de cet été elle se choisit elle-même les
danseurs c'est ce qui nous a tous la
même chose s'ils sont vraiment nd oui
parce que veut pas dire c'est apps bulté
en même temps c'est pas juste un show
puis tu vois à penne danseurs tu fais
quelques jours de terminer this tu vas
passer des mois recettes ces personnes
là tu veux pas l'énergie
y at il quelqu'un qui était chic est
toujours en retard aussi pour protéger
un peu artiste cette bulle haute et pied
un site pour eu déjà de faire se peut
donner et commises donne à chanter et à
danser
ouais accès sûr que bruce est important
de choisir leurs équipes
puis je me dis que la proximité t'es
juste du fait que sur le style a
précipité et plus et plus prochain pis
pour les reptiles plus de répète avec le
danseur j'imagine que les dents sur des
plus proches qu'ils mettront le band et
de l'artiste ouais bien ici l être quand
même très anton pour le bien de s'y
piquer ce qui est musique tout ça fait
10 répète avec eutelsat est ajustée en
2007 à peu près qui a décidé que la y
aller avec juste des femmes
c'est ce parcours actuel super impliqué
là dedans j'essaie de penser c'est sûr
que jello qui elle était danseuse avant
elle a dansé super important fac avoir
passé beaucoup plus de temps avec nous
qu'avec le berne total figure
puis l'homme est en question le question
que toute votre doigt posé souvent le
sait mais ton très bien ici c'est on a
rarement accès à comac et comment qui
allie danse parce qu'ils étaient très
peu l'entrevue sur scène c'est tout stg
même qui est capable c'est vraiment des
discours factice et rocket lavoie roux
naturel c'est tout au-dessus axé cette
personne nommé quelqu'un travaille
jamais sa personne mais on a quand même
accès mais je dirais pas mal ça c'est ce
que tu imagines de bien tissé sa qualité
c'est pas trop fort offre de hockey
c'est quelqu'un qui privé aussi quand
kate seul camp keitel sa famille en
tournée vague le ticket beaux jours de
folie et girly gens qu'il en était quand
même très sérieuse travail for peace et
on est ici pour une raison pileczko
pitié mais super fine loti que
j'adorerais c'est que être super girl
power péter niggli fi des rares elles
ont été toutes ethnies ce type 2 chez
différentes de thé pierre beaudran de
dire que c'est en parler du look pour la
tournée kim thème tes cheveux comment tu
te sens plus belle les cheveux attachés
détaché le droit de briser qu'est ce que
tu aimes en moi je me suis maman qui
fait ça si tu veux te sens bien tout
jacquet est vraiment impliqué a su
parler dit on fait toujours de brière
man show de tout mais c'est sûr qu'on
est pas jami jami
on va prendre un café ensemble pas trop
la dépasser parce que c'est là que ça
peut devenir pas vraiment de moment où
est ce que c'est
nous n'abordons pas avec 40 cas mais on
adore on va dire des courses chez zynga
que je fais beaucoup de petits voyages
par ci par là avec lt ont dû devenu plus
amis depuis tout petit je veux pas dire
qu'elle prend pas au sérieux parce qu'à
6 mais aussi super groupe c mais ça va
être souvent aidés ou en faisant des
gens des mariages août c'est du monde
qui ont fait de l'argent oui c'est fou
ces mouches et mougins si je fais des
mariages des décors pour 3,6 mais il ya
vraiment des articles il revendique au
repos à un niveau le j'ai fait avec elle
des expériences afin que pendant 24
heures sur le gouffre api de nelly qu'il
a aussi pu tenir plus et toute
performance privé pour 30 personnes que
la pression manière forme par 10 le top
personne a droit d'avoir des s'il est
des fois il est là but alex et ses
débuts pour qui l'argent
aucune valeur on est en turquie pour un
mariage encore avec l'école puis y être
invité à souper après honnêtement je
caviar de la première fois puis non mais
c'est quoi ce type là c'est je pense un
mariage russe a tué pour eux j'imagine
tradition que pour la place de type est
issu des serveurs tout ça et pitch des
100 piasses mais descend et des
sentiments je voyais à qui mon loyer
tous deux partagent le goût des rameurs
city mais c'était pour arrêt des choses
qu'on voit le cdmm rien avec l'école à
cause que ces situations là on se permet
la pièce sortir deux soirs les shoots et
un jeans consensus puisqu'il moyenne
proximité la ailleurs
[Rires]
c'est une fois king corpo la wii qui y
en a qui se paye le soleil ça aux 15
titres soirée avec ni aux pieds tous les
artistes
comment qui ont déboursé pour une soirée
cette traque est un tout petit peu
laitiers a maintenant que je le prends
tes l'argent c'est parti le problème
allemands des milliards da j'entendais
comme pour eux il ya un gars qui
écrivent sur mende
ça tombe bien puisque aujourd'hui la
marche qui va écrire un catamaran qui
ramassait le placide d'un océan ça
valait 10 millions jusqu'ici
puis il disait que selon son estime avec
dix de ces bateaux là pendant quatre ans
à se promener à temps plein il pourrait
été nettoyé tout les océans du plastique
confirmant cette dacic il comprit mais
vraiment petit petit petit puis il ya
pour surfer romance épique lignée de son
exacte il gelait cap en 4 1 avec 10 de
ces bateaux là les océans serait clé
quand je pense à seuls 10 millions pour
un des bateaux là il ya du monde font
des partis qui seraient capables de se
payer ce flou complet avec une soirée
party c'est dégueulasse en europe
ok on va marcher dans la rue pour que je
fais vraiment luge vont encore plus loin
dans la parenthèse façon rien de méthyle
l'autre jour c'était à radio j'entendais
le les achats de nouvel équipement
militaire
c'est encore une fois sous marin une des
nouveaux avions 400 milliards 7,7
vraiment besoin dé 4,5 milliards
d'équipements militaires ou de reprendre
coupe des milliards de ce pigeon régler
beaucoup de problèmes
à 3 5 milliards d'équipements militaires
près de 100 milliards pour le maître
d'art autre chose c'est qu'il marie
d'argent à triesman qui marche pas mais
ce qui manque d'argent
[Rires]
meiway setec maintenant j'avais j'avais
une question
initialement la danse pour toi est ce
que c'était un moyen d'expression qui
tape que titre que tu avais besoin par
exemple c'est souvent les domaines
artistiques c'était besoin moyen
d'expression pour laisser sortir quelque
chose juste pour être bien
je pense que je me suis pas tendu où
j'ai comme pas vraiment pensé à ça au
début moi c'est à ces femmes salle alors
qui sait vraiment plus pour le fun mais
si tu commences à faire de plus en plus
clair ces deux sites différents
il ya des styles plus on veut justement
quand c'est plus émotionnelle comme du
contemporain aussi plus l'eau surtout si
tu n'es pas sur des chansons sur
lesquelles du temps ça peut vraiment
devenir tdp venir te chercher puis si
c'est une belle façon justement la série
j'ai commencé à comprendre qui je peux
vraiment utilisé comme thérapie aussi
points puis est ce que quand vous avez
comme la deuxième partie la question
c'est ce que quand tu arrives sur des
gros shows montée comme se place une
tournée mondiale qui est ce que tu perds
un peu ce qu'est ce que des fois comme
les chorégraphies c'est que ça commence
répétitif est-ce que tu as l'impression
que ça est ce qu'une espèce de sentiment
d'expression de plaisir à ce que ça
disparaît un petit peu pour plus
l'aspect travail au noir à l'occasion
ça va dépendre des styles je pense c'est
comme si un numéro que je faisais avec
beyoncé qui était plus contemporain
justement c'était plus selon j'avais le
temps de les placer vous mange t est un
solo j'avais sur le web
j'avais comme le temps de suivre
orbis dans l'audience tout sauter mais
après sa comparse on va dire c'est
gérard lopez est traitée à jouer sur
word berne le show débute tous les
beaucoup d'équipés ce qu'on peut appeler
cela un petit peu de cruden signe que
c'est très un et deux et trois enfants
il faut un visuel global mais si tu
regardes un danseur les danseurs fait
juste comme que clic c'est comme nous
allons le faire tu es beaucoup de
mouvements saccadés au mont sutton howey
c'est ce type i c'est sûr que ça vient
pas vous savez moi me chercher là
toujours pas être comme un oui je me
sens bien en faisant comparé à quelque
chose que je fais un petit peu plus
c'est fluide on gentil fait que ça va
dépendre du style mais c'est sûr que je
veux pas quantifié train de faire 130
quelque chose pareille
c'est fou de foot donne des propres et
difficiles aujourd'hui je vois c'est de
faire ça aujourd'hui je vois si de
sortir de ma zone de confort en allant
sur la scène à la place ou regardent en
toute légèreté d'horreur où être
dépendant des spots aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup nos positions de sommets des
foyers des profitations outils embarqués
puis je sais avec le dialogue et
chercher d'autres choses du monde si que
tu connais qui sont là ça donne un boost
de plus à la tête
cette motivation laquelle le fun au
cinéma dans chaussée plus ouverts points
à 3 dans les shows que moi j'ai fait en
général ou à une activité quand même
chanceux je tombe sur le monde qui aime
beaucoup la danse la spa commissions de
gestion ou de numéros dans leur concert
de deux heures la d'habitude on est là
au moins pour monde on se tourne c'est
moins taxés de la plaça à s'amuser
parfaite à faire un petit peu différent
chaque fois c est ce qu est ce qu tu
danses pour toi mais ce que des fois de
chez vous puis dans un oui oui oui
absolument
avec même pas la pensée de comme
pratiqué quelques journalistes de danse
de la musique et du mental djembé qu'est
ce qui vous a plu et musikwelle faxer ce
qui peut jouer puis je m'amuse dans mon
salon puis comme si personne à regarder
mais personne ne regarde moi qui sait ça
c'est vrai mais c'est faux de ne pas
avoir cette pression là que ça peut être
ne pas être beau et bizarres ou out pas
qui je suis
j'imagine que le salon d'un danseur et
d'aménager
créée voilà temps c'est vrai oui moi
quelqu'un qui aime pas mariée à un
miroir c'est pas tout le monde qui m'a
même quand je chorégraphie où certaines
montagnes chorégraphie je la fais
piégeux des fois je loue un studio pour
avoir la place je me mets de l'autre
bord
le miroir et la moto du parce qu'on
dirait que je ne veux pas être
influencée par des kwassas là je veux
avoir le feeling de comment je me sens
qu avoir fêté puis la pression jamais
sûr du monde puis je vois de quoi
s'alarmer jeudi soir mais vous êtes
vraiment des passionnés sur mamma mia
gens les filles danser toute la journée
les fip et légumes noix puis on sortait
le swap il le fallait en place tout ce
qui est important mais notre antenne ça
ça change un peu la donne
il faut parce que report à deux millions
avec ça c'est qu'un petit peu vivre bien
de ça puisque ça c'est beaucoup de
sacrifices comme on parlait au début
octobre sa peau vraiment que tu aimes
soit parce que les conditions sont
difficiles
souvent tu étais comme dans le mode dans
vos dire s'ils parlent de priorités même
pour un gros spectacle the man tournée
c'est le cookie là où le burn out c'est
souvent les danseurs c'est comme si ceux
à qui tu vas demander est ce que m deux
par chambre
comme ça quand des enfants mais non
j'étais adulte j'aimerais ça ma propre
chambre en tournée supplétifs d'affaires
dément que les conditions des fois ceux
prévus dans ces crs au metit que c'est
madame ou chimie siens puis comme les
dents sable et médiatique en général crs
dematic beaucoup d'appelés peu d'élus tu
dis en bout de ligne l'offre et la
demande fait que si tu acceptes pas ces
conditions aulas ou si tu le fais pas
outillé que notre vouloir la faire on
n'est jamais si c'est vraiment plus
facile convient dans une banque capable
de messi mieux payés travaille dans une
banque mais il va avoir plus de monde
qui aimerait savoir ce qu'on fait par
exemple ça qui est difficile je pense
avait jamais vraiment changé
malheureusement ces jeux
les conditions sont meilleures que le
salaire de base monde et nous mais qui
peut dire non pitié même mois le caribou
ça fait bizarre j'ai fait telle et telle
et telle personne jarry puis demande un
peu plus d'argent que ceux avec qui je
danse 1 pour que tu te prends du monde
est donc tout aussi bonne que toi puis
ça va faire la fête il y en a tellement
de danseurs qui sont prévues sur tout ce
qui est nouveau c'est quand ils vont pas
secrètes sur leur cv
il faut être solidaire qu'il faut il
faut se tenir là-dedans mais surtout
c'est ce qu'a quand tu commences tu veux
travailler pitt a besoin d'expérience
pour travailler plus mettez josek la
gangue justement c'était team's expliqué
s'il connaît bien leur vie mais qu'il
roulait pas sur l'or
vous êtes les meilleurs vous êtes le top
dans votre domaine jarre puis vous
faites tout fait la voie au fait les
gémeaux vous faites les comédies
musicales genre vous mériteriez d'être
t4 meilleurs dans ce que tu fais tu
mériterais d'avoir des revenus en
conséquence puis c'est paul quiles que
ça c'est un petit peu mieux encore
impose aux états unis les salaires sont
mieux mais c'est ce poste ce après que
c'est quand qu'on pense aux justement
aux athlètes les plus importants les
plus populaires auquel n'importe quel
sport lisboa way toujours problématique
pittis avait pas dire que parce que tout
revient d'une tournée asiatique après ça
tu vois je sois des gros jobs loin
gênant même je sais c'est quoi le pigeon
pas dire non à le bar mitzvah qui sans
vie après cette époque édimbourg et
parce que si j'avais qu'est ce qui rend
inquiet de sa ronde puis il faut parce
que l'hôte et des je suis top et c'est
arrivé ce qui se passe dans vos parties
brunes ne m'arrive qu'est ce que c'est
une vieille brume
c'est comme si la piste ça me garde
meuble machine ailleurs il ya quelque
chose de vraiment catharsique avec la
danse viscéral si on était j'avais un
mariage la fin de semaine passée le pis
a mené pendant la soirée tout le monde
des commandants le mois pin gang d'amis
tous des amis mangeurs le che la date
des médecins et des enjeux
travaillant finances puis comme une
donne qui part plus on est juste comme 8
go qui ont qui sont 0,10 dansant sur un
patio pleut en fait jusqu'à me demande
comment son est sûr qu on était chauds
un peu mais troquant sa danse et puis
comme juste faire on faisait n'importe
quoi avec notre corps le ouais mais il
s'était quand même moment que à ce
moment le personnes jugées personne
personne avec d'attendre par rapport à
rien puis le réflexe primaire de toutes
les gosses et de juste faire les pires
moments de l'histoire puis de jeu s'est
laissé aller sans aucun jugement juste
parce que je sais pas y avait il y avait
sur ce qui était la nounou qui a
nécessité de sortir d'avoir c'est
justement cette sécurité l'en tant que
groupe j'imagine vous connaissez tout
pouvoir exerce savoir que c'est une
place de non jugement puis on se salit
psy on pouvait répliquer c'est un peu
par tout ça serait tellement merveilleux
ce marché loos puis s'amuser comme cela
dans ça fait tellement du bien de ce
multi communique avec ton corps c'est
une façon de parler aussi
ouais c'est vraiment quelque chose de
libérateur là dedans le système expliqué
mais relativement introverti by georges
mélies moment où est ce que george me
dis fuck off qui loge dans ce fait ils
sont justement c'est que c'était la zone
de non jugement à ce moment là mais le
lendemain matin quinconces et réveillon
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait la
blonde d'un des gueux qui était venu sni
qui tient on à l'ars de 8 go sous lsd
faut que je serais parti à l'avant qui
criait exprimez-vous les gueules
exprimez vous
geluck tout athlète qui sont là
m'exprimer de l'art vidéo d'archivé gelé
[Rires]
j'adore mais c'est parce qu'il est il
faut être fatal avec soi-même quand même
pas pour se permettre de dancing ouais
ouais surtout tout dépendant de les jobs
que tu fais tu vas les options put a
peut-être juste le titre de la chanson
qui l'artiste sort juste l'artiste belga
la chambre froide et embarque le tout
par des puits justement moi quand j'ai
fait j'ai zappé les robots ouais c'est
ça c'est une orgie de rabot c'est
vraiment ça doit être tout bois je dois
pas cette description là j'avais passé
justin parce que les mots que ça soit
trop immense c'est vraiment curieux
comme quand on choisit sélectionner
certaines personnes pour défaire
l'édition qui m'a aussi surpris quand
arrive le toulouse nice et son
chorégraphe à lui son équipe et nos
coûts et nous dit bon ben c'est pas pour
je pensais
margarito ne pas troquer t on il rentre
si tu penses que tu arrives pour une pub
peut-être tout c'est de la danse on
arrive la boc du bon ben là peut-être
devenu parce que l'on avait jean plein
papiasse ni pourquoi parler la chanson
du clip de justin timberlake
voici la chanson au pied des voies si
accord il est hyper édition de sa place
et ça j'étais choisi d'aller humer
au début je sais pas quoi à quoi
t'attendre le style qui finissent par te
raconter bon ben vous allez être comme
pas trop trop habillée c'est comme un
orgie avec un robot au patriote aux
beaux jours
métis était fait et les classes c'est du
beau monde ce qui doit surtout danseurs
justement le chorégraphe si un de ses
meilleurs amis qui est hâtif qui est
super pour les danseurs diesel pour les
world shopping la création il demandait
5 est confortable avec ce qu'on faisait
à tout mais c'est ça vous botte si
jamais un coup de sang barque votait pas
de dire excusez moi c'est pas pour moi
je désolé du poppers honda mais je
mangerai pas prête à faire ça au moins
c'est propre et a raté sa sortie j'ai
quand même fait split qui m'ouvre les
jambes j'ai passé des vidéoclips le mec
j'ai vu mais leur écoute et anéantir l
écart s est s étaient élevées pour
protéger sa date de glam plus de fans
sur la vidéo mais faute nette sur le
plateau de la demande qui nous regardent
drones qui filme du monde qu'on peut
vraiment à part l'a peut-être en train
de passer mouvement l'autre si c'est pas
toujours évident à m'écouter de la
confiance en toi minceur joueurs issus
des situations où est-ce que tu étais
pas les housses que c'était ce qui était
demandé si je rêve c'est de mauvais goût
non je pense pas non non je pense les
récentes avancent aussi doit faire ses
affaires le phare fucking c'est quand tu
es l'homme et ont justement le tlm est
honteux pas la pole et le col qui fait
que ça commence à la grippe le plus
savoir plus et s'offrir des geeks chez
10 des clips le sait plus démagogiques
et des danseurs mettons des clips de rap
lorsqu'elle est fixé sont 1 cm et texas
et chamakh
non non non ouais ou si j'ai déjà vu des
descriptifs l'audition comme témoin tout
dépendante et je peux te dire je
comprends que c'est jouer un personnage
ne veut pas silverman acteur dans un
film quoi que ce soit et si un scénario
puis ça fait partie de
la mise en scène de l'histoire mais
c'est bien fait cesser
ça serait juste et la sexualité pour la
sexualité pour voir on doit qu'à pas de
démarche artistique ou que pau 2 c'est
de mauvais goût car là c'est ça le
travail sur les gémeaux qui viennent
passer avec une compagnie où est ce
qu'on fait de la nourriture sur le ca
est en en donnait de la bouffe à l'afp à
partir d'alger mon enfant faisant à la
fois des gémeaux puis tout le monde est
arrivé en deçà et à vos yeux un feu jeu
stérile et ne l'avait de la promenade
dans la basse le numéro d'ouverture
ouais exactement avec moi je citais
samuel chouinard qui faisait la
chorégraphie de le numéro d'ouverture
avec avec véronique patier puis la fin
la finale ya comme une douche qu'on
appelle un peu de pied roule dans de
petits plats mersch qui tombe pendant
que quick change pas rapidement pour
commencer le gala puis en une qui
restait allumée mais le tout le long t
pobel l apal puis à commençons galope et
c'est juste puis l'otan
ça fait juste parler parce qu'on voit la
flamme les deux bouts de feuilleton ça
s'était rendu sacem et ils ont disparu
elle a continué la vie continue at il
promis à la pipe et sa part fait une
coupe dodge en piste est parfait comme
athée mais c'est après caribou soit
prête à tout - c'est à la fin c'est
pouvoir qui dans sa danse et je voudrais
pas altérer votre performance était
vraiment sur des gros et et des grosses
tournées
c'est sûr que ya pas de danseurs sur
cholet les mettons témoin je pense à
rammstein ou est ce qui est quand même
eu l'audace et des explosions puis des
affaires de fou mais sur des grosses
tournées bien aussi doit avoir sauce il
dit
tout étudiant au dessus des mauviettes
eu des fois où ce qui est vraiment ça
c'est parti comblement sous le seul nom
s'est jamais vraiment arriver mais si on
est vraiment un briefing qu'il avait
cassé la jambe que tu une approche web
deuxième couplet at-elle la faire quand
elop et par là les deux danseurs qui
sont proches de la flamme des puis
mettez pas de prix nets dans vos cheveux
sur les fictions là où tu es vraiment un
groupe défini prennent pas ça la légende
du tout du tout le système portant de 11
ans parle avant chaque show puis c'est
fou que ça devrait apparaître pour une
automatique qui va pas juste acquis
c'est mon cul pour la flamme 6 2 j'étais
quelqu'un trop poche mais on s'occupe le
foot ou bad the way terme et était moins
d'accidents ou de trucs plate comme ça
non j'ai une amie que je peux vous en
avez vous entendu parler ce point mais
ce n'est minami disons le c'est une
fille dans la danse que je connaissais
quelques justes et fait mort par le
groupe sert pas que nicki minaj la
faconde focale 100 parce qu'il
s'affairait plusieurs fois qu'ils
faisaient numéros plus le serpent petit
je pense que tu as fait de dire qu'il
faut que c'est fini noter le nombre de
lumières de son plein musique fort que
rita baus et nicki minaj non une autre
fois la fia s'est faite mans le serpent
nicki minaj débat mais ouais c'est fou
sur un axe est sous sa moye a beaucoup
de ma fonction qu'on appelle là avec mon
costume grise il mettait en pleine
numéro assez d'attendre c'est ce que
c'est à lui à viande c'est justement de
ses cheveux il est aussi c'était un show
télévisé le pied à free toutankhamon
plusieurs fois c'est le premier soir de
coacher de away qu'elle avait de la
mesure où tu es mon talon qui brisent
numéro viennent de commencer pour le 2 3
numéros bac barça - des pieds et un
soulier qui a pas de talent mais pas
cette image la sudîles un talon teaser
c'est loin je l'espère plus t'en fous tu
deviens habitués à gérer sa moitié des
fois mes temps je voyais un clip
le guide qui ce genre il joue de la
guitare guette ses cheveux paille en feu
ses cheveux vie continue à tourner comme
si de rien ça qui rend chaud le fun car
si je veux dire je ne souhaite pas
personne mais des défis aux enfers qui
est comme ça que tu t'attends pas à ce
que ça arrive
cette garde je te montre de poche wade
dalmon en prison les je me rappelle ma
niche dans celle de jennifer lopez puis
on est sur une chandelle de l'ong chaise
c'est un moment plus l'eau toute simple
du coup je la savais pas comment tu es
trop performance que je pense pas que je
commette en train de voir me dire
quelque chose mais son manque pas qu'il
y avait tombé de sa cuisse tard je m'en
bat des ailes comme série le thème le
jeu tu recherches à poche
ça fait partie encore danser intelligent
ça c'est vraiment une notion que
j'ignorais complètement le titre de
mairesse a fait tout le sens du monde
c'est juste parce que je m'étais jamais
questionné à propos de ses problèmes que
c'est la même chose dans tous les corps
de métier qui travaillent sur des aussi
grosse apparemment il ya tellement
d'imprévus possible il faut que tout le
monde sache ce soit les rowdies les
techniciens et musiciens tout le monde
faut qu'ils soient capables d'improviser
sur de quoi laisser absolument c'est le
livre qui bouge pour on passe par ou à
plat soins quelqu'un qui lance quelque
chose ça s'intitule cliquer à maclas la
finale arrive parfois c'est qu'un slip
ça va être dans son état a tous là c'est
hallucinant sur l'épreuve dames m pitié
mais ton si vous êtes les tops danseurs
ceux qui ont été sélectionnés
mais le bnc le top berne le godisson
c'est le top de son art si l'artiste la
taupe artistes ici comme titan en
environnement où tout le monde et on
attend
ça va tellement stimulant d'entourer de
monde aussi bons dans ce qu'ils font pas
aussi passionné c'est vraiment cool ce
genre fans aussi d'aller voir justement
comité les autres départements des
landes renault on danse on se connaît
bien et puis on sait quoi on sait à quoi
s'attendre mais découvrir pour voir le
centre cheikh ben tu vois comment ça
marche le livre ty si j'ai vraiment tout
le monde est tellement important des
fois ça va tellement vite puis tout a
job [ __ ] est juste concentré soi qu'il
faut chaussures cas précis puis là je
bougeais c'est un costume le genre on ne
répète pas mais quand tu t'arrêtes tu
regardes qui fait quoi tu sais c'est
tout mon job tellement important puis
c'est vraiment cool mais comme tu dis
exactement les tellement important pis
si c'est quelque chose que j'ai réalisé
justement cet été si tout le monde
tellement fait de sa job de manière
magnifique qui meti qui se voit vraiment
acquis si cette personne ne faisait pas
bien sa job
l'effet domino que sa femme cécilia un
danseur qui a pas bien sa job si les
gothys ont fait briller sa job c'est peu
importe qui est le régisseur fabien sa
job ici tout le monde car le puits pour
qu'un show de même sa fonctionne faut
que tout le monde fasse même comparé des
bodys qu'on voit pas beaucoup de si mais
aussi les premiers qui rentrent pour
faire une tournée comme seul homme est
en tournée mondiale de beyoncé je
postais combine spectacle qui vous avez
faisait des pièges passé 138 / / quand
même temps pendant 1 à cucq
après deux ans certes est tellement
difficile physiquement puis mentalement
à partir de maintenant tourné puis à
chaque soir dans ses pendants
show complet ouais c'est ça quand on
parlait du glam de tessa dare de quoi
demain c'est cool on va d'entrain de
places puis j'adore
j'en ai les chambres d'hôtel de tout
avoir l'air de when aéroports doivent
tout d'abord c'est quoi mon numéro de
chant deuxième étage mais non mais c'est
ce côté corse et c'est vraiment à bout
rond dans sa radio spécialement parce
qu'on utilise nos corps pour le show
même si des fois tu peux être tu fais
ton spectacle tu prends ta douche à
l'aréna tu embarques dans l'autobus de
tournée tu fais un 20h jusqu'à la
prochaine fois si on s'écoute et hi-fi
québec montréal le 20 heures dans nabi
stop le football c'est dans ces fous
pareils c'est beaucoup le décalage
horaire rendu notre famille si tu veux
quand tu t'attends traîné pour être
physiquement parce que quand on fait des
répétitions on danse des 10 12 14 heures
par jour
on reconnaît sa hanche et ça vaut bien
la pression tout en mains tournées dans
juste deux heures le soir quand même
acquis que je m'entraîne le matin où je
fasse quelque chose de physique pour
conter garder mashaie et puis mon cardio
peut sauter va essayer de faire tous
fêter cela s'est vraiment demandé que le
ring c'est le pen lebouc ou là mais ça
prenne discipline de fer
ouais c'est cela faire le plus souvent
mes statistiques homme est on certain le
soir l'emmène à geoffrey je fais du
sport bascule après cette chaude si nous
autres les musiciens et moi on était
dans un autre internaute salma qui nous
écoutent heures les partitions la tv si
on n'est pas comme sous le choc il dans
son temps sur le fond la carte de la
journée le bouche à six matchs
eh bien non c'est simplement une petite
fête ont tort car c'est pas faut quand
même très chaude peut-être être facile
mais que c'est quand même c'est beaucoup
surtout justement la tournée genoa le
pacte et saturn a juste fait aussi la
petite tournée j'ai même fait le titre
de moi mais on avait un show quasiment
chaque jour j'ai deux jours sinon se
déplacer ces mêmes conquérant à
l'étranger je pense qu'une journée qu'on
a fait
la turquie le jour d'après la marche en
egypte deux jours plus tard c'était
réussite et menaces avec le thé
compenser les reports la sicor 6' les
bagages bien plus dure et plus et
plusieurs global le terrible j'avais
entendu tout avait visité le terrain
d'une trentaine de pays quarante deux
pays
est ce que dans ces moments là des fois
tu dis justement du temps pour profiter
de soins ouais des pandas là sinon on va
trouver le temps justement dans ce qu'on
dit toujours on dort pas encore d'impôt
aux quatre allons dormir dans l'avion
vous faites le de nuit une coupe
d'affaires on a c'est de vraiment
profiter date et j'ai un petit j'ai fait
toutes ces pays d'olmes et c'est un peu
comme magazine c'est une demi journée
ouais je vais retourner mais j'ai pas eu
le temps de tout voir foule comme jude
réel mais certaines places mais est-ce
que c'est tourner le est-ce que c'est du
first class
les vols s'allie pas avec qik singleyrac
parce que se sachant ça ça change toute
la semaine
ouais mais non c'est sûr mais pas
n'importe qui c'est ça me coucher à la
lecture ça passe de 1 expérience qui est
vraiment épuisant à une expérience qui
est positif c'est vraiment le jour et la
nuit jamais dixit une fois je
est overbooké mon avion d'entraînement
alphonse ii on était toute la gamme qui
avait deux personnes sur les sept qui
allait alerter ses traces parce qu'on a
tiré comme parrain du tournoi de paleta
bourgeois de barive le bit of japan cup
oui encore s'il vous plaît plus à
contenu plus noté dans une espèce de
gros shoots les les first class qui sont
égales c'est vrai mais après tu peux te
coucher genre complètement allonger le
titre dont c'est vraiment la différence
parce qu'après sa dissidence dans la
classe économique en arrière depuis que
ton choix à faire le soir c'est ouais ça
dépend des artistes que je suis crise
nucléaire qui fait sa belle attention
oui vraiment ouais qu'est-ce que sa vie
pour toi mais là je m'accepte amoria
ouais je me croise les doigts parce que
l'homme vient d'annoncer shakira donc me
croise les doigts qu'on l'a rappelé pour
faire ça dans le fond le texte le des
fêtes
le super bowl c'est con mais quatre mois
de préparation mettons cela vient
d'annoncer qu'elle fait vraiment que la
presse commence maintenant
ouais c'est ça pour pour qu est ce qui
est de la prod puisque la création tout
ça je sais que si j'ai déjà vu je
connais les graphiques sont le cube qui
sont déjà en train de parler de la scène
clé logistique de tous et tout ça que ça
fait longtemps que ça commence et je
pense que les danseurs on va peut-être
embarqué était en décembre c'est
peut-être un deux mois avant la mort de
textes à voir mais je sens et quand
habituellement cet inversement
cole
pour ça dépend toujours des mélomanes
accès annoncé officiellement on va le
savoir bientôt d'après moi que oui
bim et on est ce que je sais ce que tu
es un bon feeling pour pour ce ouais
quand même
ça me surprendrait que tu ais je pense
qu'anne j'ai beaucoup aimé ont une belle
gang souvent fait le spectacle et les
corées vont peu marre resté pareil ou
quand même assez ça me parait était
souvent le look où les tensions ou
l'histoire qui va changer mais pouvait
pas les kadhafistes à peu près les mêmes
faits que ça fait dix ans de garder les
danseurs qui les connaissent et suivent
un pays un peu ce qui se passe parce
parle aussi d'un condensé son sauveur
des modules est plus des petits bouts de
doigts d'après moi je sais pas savoir
des invités de petits noms des invités
n'ont cédé camille au petit monde qui
embarque pendant quelques tours elle a
quand même fait plusieurs chansons de
mon métier comme fait beau et puis je
passe et marque un tenir et embarquerait
c'est à voir mais j'étais tellement
choqué je sais pas s'il a changé de
l'avoir en chine nouvelle c'est vraiment
spectaculaire
tu penses vraiment pas qu'elle a 50 ans
à ce propos cadence de même qu'à chambre
comme ça pour l'énergie avait vraiment
captivé tout le monde puis c'est sûr ça
va être un beau show du bronze c'est
parfait qu'elle soit celle qui fête
cette année je pense bien sûr
ouais bien miami en plus noir de bonnes
conditions
wen import on a fini la tournée aux
états unis avec trois shows sold out
what should arena j'imagine loin ses
débuts comme on aime vraiment ça va être
malade non genre de messages me
souhaitant se croise les doigts mais
sinon assez juste à montréal j'enseigne
beaucoup quand j'ai eu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui voilà
je me promène d'un studio alors d'entrer
en contact comme des jarres de master
class et indépendante sur quoi il veut
se concentrer
quelqu'un quand j'enseigne des je suis
tellement plein bonne claque un bon prof
campbell corée moi j'aime ça beaucoup
parlé de mon vécu des outils utilisés
comme quand je parlais du mental de me
parler différemment les possibilités
ceci tout à fait que j'aurais aimé ça
entendent acquis ben oui c'est exact que
wes accès se fait qu'une enfant moi
quand j'en sais que je vais vraiment
prendre cette tournure là dedans c'est
en corée mais on va aussi parler de
commandes est en ce moment en train de
l'apprendre
tu es en train de se presser parce que
des polypes à ce programme soit on peut
dont 100 % puis s'est fait que je parle
beaucoup du mental
la confiance en soi est ce que il ya
encore le che qui met tant qu'un quand
tu regardes tu t'écoutes un film comme
ton black swan cdd doit faire avec le
ballet classique pis tout pile espèce de
dépression du corps d'avoir ne pas être
trop grosses que ça existe encore
vraiment dans l'air dans ce milieu là
c'est là encore est encore dense mais
sur l'autre après ceux des fois ça va
bien avec bien aussi en tournée on en
revenait d'un show il y avait un petit
col avec une note
oui mais oui mais tu veux pas je
comprends tes c'est sûr que si on engage
choqué quand ça a changé tâche et qu'il
faut faire attention pu être dit ça
comme je souhaite à l'arrière des
artistes que tu sais que tu étais lecce
souhaite t out point que je veux ton
audition durant 38 ventes ont auditionné
lag et moi ce que le fasse de loin même
chose pour juste physiquement change ta
coupe de cheveux
tous fassent attention tu veux pas y
compris pourtant le coup ci a foutu
maintien seul le sait quel pourcentage
de temps qui passe est un livre sur ce
mauvais remède on attendait là cette
année à cause de la tournée je t'ai pas
beaucoup la faillite est que les quatre
premiers mois j'étais à les piéger pas
retourné depuis
mais d'habitude j'aime beaucoup plus
salée mais non mon copain je pense que
le club c'est fun parce que s'il fallait
que je prenne une longue distance et
c'est parfait que ce soit lui parce que
lui était déjà en amoureux claquer du
fort ni ça fait plusieurs années qu'il
vient en californie après comme parfait
comme comme match de sion se dire qu'on
va nous était à montréal puis n'oserait
en californie puis ta vie avec des
artistes puissent pas ce que veut pas si
c'est un métier très physique mais une
date d'expiration caribou qui est ce qu
est ce que tu vas faire sont encore
plusieurs années est ce que tu veux
transitionner plus voir le coaching
ouvert le way
mais c'est ce que je pense je dirais que
je suis en transition battus à
renseigner un peu plus c'est encore elle
qui a donné du temps pour soi avant
c'était non je dis pas oui à rien
d'autre parce que je vais disponibles
pour la job pour le terrain qui peut
sonner maintenance et non ses excuses
moi je peux pas faire tel vidéoclip
parce que je suis à montréal puis
janssen qu'elle était classée
je me permets tranquillement pas vite
j'ai pas envie de danser par exemple je
pense que je suis un petit peu plus mais
qui par rapport avec qui je veux danse
il savait de quoi il avait quitté
l'équipe si je veux que les conditions
soient soient bonnes puis je sois une
guigne pris parti c'est pas si je pus
rendu vraiment comme que j'ai besoin du
nom de la personne pour mettre mon cv
mais plus de nouveaux titres se gagnent
coince et si oui à qui gomme au détour d
une souris relier déjà ces gars là est
ce que tu te tue des envies de famille
de deux enfants est ce que tu es ce que
tu ressens ce ouais je ressens mais je
quelqu'un qui est très vive dans la
présence de plus en plus c'est quelque
chose que j'essaie d'adapter puis
justement fred est très bon là-dedans
aux sites et il me dit toujours soyons
flexible soit complexe il faudrait
commencer par vivre dans même pays il
faudrait en effet que quand même des
étapes
mais c'est sûr que ceux ci l'homme de ma
vie puis et si on s'est trouvé puis on
se laissera pas prendre ça suive qu'est
ce qui va se passer après le mais c'est
sûr qu'une dame est
c'est beau c'est l'fun mais on souhaite
tout le bonheur du monde
on espère vraiment pour toi pendant
cannes paca de sortie ou humain merci
plaisir à faire espérer qu'ils avaient
peint les chocs qui ont une chance qu'on
veut pas se lève chaque c'est mon ami
c'est lui qui était qu'ils avaient
raison comme un condensé
je suis pour ceux qui nous écoutent sont
pas au courant de l'histoire de l'équipe
et justement et ça c'est plus plat que
tout du goût des xsara qui a fait ça
cette courbe l'improvisation
qu'est ce que tu veux si tu as posé
match et mai 1,1 kg comme témoin fait
faux là c'est plus un mix connais parce
que comme après celui jeu le mime
c'était un requin et fécamp savais pas
que c'était lui est ses mais lui comme
un lieu commun qui pense qu'il faudra
faire les entrevues après tout ça je
pense qu'il doit porter trop dire à 100%
le jeu mais pendant mais maintenant je
fais pour ce jeu peut suivre mais je
pense s'était fait dire type d'entrevue
sur ce fait parfois trop c'est ça ou le
château de tongs ont regardé l'énergie
sur qui
les chaussures sur internet se sont
emparés de ouais je veux tellement
rapide en plus la potence les mym qui se
passe c'est tellement quelque chose de
marquer savoir quelqu'un le remarque
mais une fois que tu vois par exemple
même si parfois il ya des raisons quatre
voisins en plus en plus dans cholet qui
est hyper u à la rive sur un genre de
gros cheval est ici tout ceci massif le
tice et un homme puis la chaussée